here with alareza ferrugia who has won a
huge game alert so first of all
congratulations on your win when you
were preparing for this game did you
ever did it cross your mind that this
might be worth about a hundred thousand
dollars
uh
i don't know yeah all the games are
important here because there are a few
rounds
so eight rounds it's kind of like uh you
have to be paid you have to be alert
every round so
um
yeah it was a very strange game at the
first he surprised me with a5 of course
of course i knew the move but
but
i didn't expect him to play normally
there are
better tries of course for black but he
wanted to surprise me i guess and yeah i
think knight bd2 b3 i knew
and uh
yeah rookies and here maybe i should
have played better i mean
the way i played i think during the game
i was under a lot of pressures and i
should improve here somehow some move i
don't know yeah the main move according
to the database which has been played
many times is bishop b5 yeah probably
it's a better move because the way i
played i unders i completely
underestimated the knight h5 move how
did you feel after this 985 came on the
board yeah i felt kind of uh
kind of stupid because it's kind of only
move if he goes back
it's i'm better so i mean this happens
right i mean you cannot defend the pawn
in a proper way so i should have
calculated this when i played this kind
of bishop b2 bishop before so
yeah i underestimated the move and
i still think that i could hold here but
this precise play was very difficult so
i thought knight c4 is
kind of only move queen f6 is a very
good move
takes takes knight d5
and bishop h3 of course he has this rook
d8 also here yeah what were you planning
to do i wanted to know d3 and here it's
very i don't know if bishop h3 works
but uh
i don't know what how he has to play
maybe knight f4 knight d4 bishop b3 i
was thinking but i don't know if it
works there should be three well the
engine was suggesting to start with this
move
ah okay queen takes
rook d3 queen c4 this is what i wanted
to play yeah rook f3 and then knight of
four and it's just everything collapses
yeah no no no no no
c5 knight in c5 but then like the four
anyway oh yes this is crushing yeah
93 just a little bit too strong okay is
this losing or pretty much yeah uh wow
yeah actually the engines think that
you're already lost here completely
can i how can i hold here i mean let me
try the angel was adamant about bishop
a3 or b4 okay trying to just get rid of
it yeah i sucked before i should have
gone for b4 probably i don't think you
should have gone for b4 considering the
game yeah and
yeah but he was he didn't think about
bishop xp3 because he wanted only two
mates right right i mean makes makes a
lot of sense yes so we got to this
position after knight d3 um very
important yeah
what did you expect here um i i expected
rook d8 right right there in this knife
d4 queen g6 coin f3 bishop g4 23 and
here bishop b6 maybe yes very strong yes
because i don't have c4 bishop d4 coin
d6 this is what i blundered oh c4 yes
yeah if i have c4 c5 i'm better but i
blended bishop d4 i was calculating this
bishop d4 yeah
d6 this is
fascinating you can also start with uh i
think if i remember this correctly you
can start with this yeah because there's
bishop f3 in the end as well yeah
okay
yeah
anyways winning but i have some defense
maybe after bishop b6 bishop a3 maybe
huh
and this is where it comes yeah this is
this is the one we thought
yeah rook d4 wins wow
that's crazy
same idea yeah i am no okay
then i'm losing red after bishop b6 i
mean you're you're losing here
yeah yeah yeah you're losing after rogue
d.a there's just no defense
but you got a little bit of a breath of
hope after queen g6 yes here i'm still
worse probably but okay at least i'm
playing
and knight h4 when they move yeah all
the moves or only move i guess i didn't
see better trying queen g5 and knight c5
h4 yeah here actually we expected rook
to d8
yes okay
yeah but after queen h4 yeah gh rookie 5
doesn't work i was thinking a lot about
this what did you calculate i wanted to
go bishop c one at the end i couldn't
find b one here yeah
rook c5 coin g4 and just bail out i mean
yes take stakes
and knight f6 and just f3 or c4 or c4 c4
maybe i said let's see if i give up the
g4 probably then bishop f4 yes
and i think this is i still maybe
i'm not better but okay i'm playing
it's very unclear the engine's thinking
that this was unclear also that queen d4
wasn't clear surprisingly just catching
the rook oh okay but
what you said was just as good okay i
missed queen before yeah so after he
goes queen g5 check queen g4 he takes on
c5 he goes c4
what did you expect from him yeah here i
felt it's very tricky getting tricky for
him
but i thought look v8 is correct
actually
and
he could go for these four pawns against
the peace position this is what i
thought
and i don't know i think it's round
equal that one because it's okay rook b3
bishop d4 takes special e3
takes takes rookie five takes takes
and uh
first i thought i am winning with rook
c1 but he has rook before which is very
strong because i cannot take rook g4 i
lose yeah oh that's nice yes
so
yeah i thought then maybe after rook b4
29
then i no no sorry instead of rook c1
then i should go rook eb1
and then i think it's round equal rook
d3
or rook c3 i don't know under rook b7
okay i'm a little better because because
of the pawn on a5 but i think it's
holdable for black yeah we were debating
in the studio if it was holdable or not
the angels do think it's a very large
advantage for the white side so rookbane
you expected you thought he was going to
go for the four pawn end game he plays
g6
right no this is very bad right well
what did you think yeah i saw this just
completely then i saw bishop first time
when did you see bishop bathroom yeah
then he played and then i thought about
one minute then i saw which of these
three it's
just over i think he has to go before
even yeah actually they all lose yes as
much but
did you
sorry when you played the move uh when
you played the movie kb and you played
e5 you did not expect him to play g6 no
i thought he has to go for four points
right right but he picked but you hadn't
seen bishop a3 no but i felt that after
g6 i'm meaning i mean
maybe first i thought okay i was still
in the mood of trying to bailing out
so i said at the worst case i could go
e6 g5 and go to this end game so i was
happy already so this was
and then when it appeared on the board i
found bishop v3 yeah and then the game
is pretty much over yes
there is an incredible turnaround here
of events for you going from losing to
winning in a crucial game st louis your
lucky city
yes
yeah it's still a very big game tomorrow
of course against maxime i have black so
um it will be very interesting i think
jan is also winning so well he was but
uh i do not know if he is anymore they
have reached mu 40 this is a crucial
game for the standings absolutely
uh actually how would you evaluate this
uh but before that was completely
winning right there yes absolutely levon
had no move
but yeah somehow he got this
okay this could go other
anyway right i mean it's like my game
actually
because the pawn on a5 could be very
tricky at some point that's right it's
true it could be queen
well guys join the conversation
ali reza first of all uh congratulations
quite the turnaround today quite the
turnaround uh from
chakriar as well um
just the chakra game that you've had
that you've won from a losing position
right
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
what are you doing uh you're hypnotizing
your opponents there
i am getting lucky that's if they don't
be precise i have been
my position has some dynamic and somehow
uh of course against sharia was a very
bad blunder so
um yeah it's it's uh
strange but okay somehow sometimes in
this turn of tournaments you have you
get lucky so
um
yeah what can i say
there's there's no there's no vlog
shaming on this show yeah
we've all been recipients of
very very good luck um
big game tomorrow against mvl how have
you
done in the past
when you've faced mvl yeah i think we
have many draws um
i don't remember if we made even one win
or lose but okay we didn't play much i
mean we played some i think i beat you
in bucharest
oh yes he beat me in boogers
and i lost that in at the end right yeah
yeah that was a strange game but yeah in
general um
he's a very strong player so
um we will see what is going to happen
tomorrow there is a huge game tomorrow
we'll let you prep for that one
congratulations on your game thank you